- So we have different definitions
for d of t on the left and the right
and let's say that d is
distance and t is time,
so this is giving us our
distance as a function of time,
on the left, it's equal to 3t plus one
and you can see the graph
of how distance is changing
as a function of time here is a line
and just as a review from algebra,
the rate of change of a line,
we refer to as the slope of a
line and we can figure it out,
we can figure out, well,
for any change in time,
what is our change in distance?
And so in this situation,
if we're going from time
equal one to time equal two,
our change in time,
delta t is equal to one
and what is our change in distance?
We go from distance is
equal to four meters,
at time equals one,
to distance in seven
meters at time equal two
and so our change in distance
here is equal to three
and if we wanna put our units,
it's three meters for
every one second in time
and so our slope would be
our change in our vertical
divided by our change in our horizontal,
which would be change in
d, delta d over delta t,
which is equal to three over one
or we could just write that
as three meters per second
and you might recognize this as a rate,
if you're thinking about
your change in distance
over change in time,
this rate right over here
is going to be your speed.
This is all a review of
what you've seen before
and what's interesting about a line,
or if we're talking
about a linear function,
is that your rate does
not change at any point,
the slope of this line
between any two points
is always going to be three,
but what's interesting about
this function on the right
is that is not true,
our rate of change is constantly changing
and we're going to study
that in a lot more depth,
when we get to differential calculus
and really this video's a little bit
of a foundational primer
for that future state,
where we learn about differential calculus
and the thing to appreciate here
is think about the instantaneous
rate of change someplace,
so let's say right over there,
if you ever think about
the slope of a line,
that just barely touches this graph,
it might look something like that,
the slope of a tangent line
and then right over here,
it looks like it's a little bit steeper
and then over here, it looks
like it's a little bit steeper,
so it looks like your rate of change
is increasing as t increases.
As I mentioned, we will build the tools
to later think about
instantaneous rate of change,
but what we can start to think about
is an average rate of change,
average rate
of change,
and the way that we think about
our average rate of change
is we use the same tools, that
we first learned in algebra,
we think about slopes of secant lines,
what is a secant line?
Well, we talk about this in geometry,
that a secant is something
that intersects a curve
in two points, so let's
say that there's a line,
that intersects at t equals
zero and t equals one
and so let me draw that
line, I'll draw it in orange,
so this right over here is a secant line
and you could do the
slope of the secant line
as the average rate of change
from t equals zero to t equals one,
well, what is that average
rate of change going to be?
Well, the slope of our
secant line is going to be
our change in distance
divided by our change in time,
which is going to be equal to,
well, our change in time is one second,
one, I'll put the units here, one second
and what is our change in distance?
At t equals zero or d of zero is one
and d of one is two,
so our distance has
increased by one meter,
so we've gone one meter in one second
or we could say that our
average rate of change
over that first second from t equals zero,
t equals one is one meter per second,
but let's think about what it is,
if we're going from t equals two
to t equals three.
Well, once again, we can
look at this secant line
and we can figure out its slope,
so the slope here,
which you could also use
the average rate of change
from t equals two to t equals three,
as I already mentioned,
the rate of change seems
to be constantly changing,
but we can think about
the average rate of change
and so that's going to
be our change in distance
over our change in time,
which is going to be equal
to when t is equal to two,
our distance is equal to five,
so one, two, three, four, five,
so that's five right over there
and when t is equal to three,
our distance is equal to 10,
six, seven, eight, nine, 10,
so that is 10 right over there,
so our change in time, that's
pretty straightforward,
we've just gone forward one
second, so that's one second
and then our change in
distance right over here,
we go from five meters to
10 meters is five meters,
so this is equal to five meters per second
and so this makes it very clear,
that our average rate
of change has changed
from t equals zero, t equals one
to t equals two to t equals three,
our average rate of change is higher
on this second interval,
than on this first one
and as you can imagine,
something very interesting to think about
is what if you were to take the slope
of the secant line of
closer and closer points?
Well, then you would get closer and closer
to approximating that
slope of the tangent line
and that's actually what we
will do when we get to calculus.